et bon soir amélie tirs bonsoir
bienvenue sur ce plateau artistique
vinoy grosse journée pour vous depuis
deux jours vous êtes en plein tournage
du clip qui va accompagner la sortie
d'un album l'album montrouge c'est long
du clip également que c'est en train de
tourner ce premier titre on va en parler
mais déjà un mot sur vous peut-être
auteur compositeur interprète et vous
avez commencé comme batteur comme
musicien aujourd'hui vous avez envie
d'être sous les feux de la rampe en
pleine lumière devancé sa vie le chemin
est assez long en fait j'ai commencé
très jeune par le chant dans les
chorales et puis oui la batterie vers
l'âge de 13 14 ans et puis j'ai fait la
comédie j'ai fait beaucoup de choses
aussi pour en arriver justement à cet
album parce que en fait sur la batterie
on s'exprime pas forcément positive
frustré en fait en quelque sorte ce type
si c'est pas une question de frustration
c'est en fait c'est on accompagne les
autres les autres apportent leurs
messages s'exprimer puis nous moi qu'on
voit là qu'un jour on avec la maturité
on a envie aussi de s'exprimer alors cet
album va parler de quoi alors cet album
il parle un petit peu justement une
actualité un petit peu morose ça parle
un petit peu de choses d'amour de soleil
de choses qu'il manque un petit peu dans
notre société actuellement fait et le
premier titre qui sera extrait ses
mandants simon forcément c'est lié avec
cette thématique autour de l'amour si
vous voulez c'est un petit peu le mot
qu'on dit à la femme qu'on aime on
l'appelle mon âge on donne des petits
mots gentils comme ça voilà c'est pour
ça que j'ai appelé ça me touche et vous
tourner le clip un mot sur le clip on va
en voir quelques images dans un instant
de cet extrait alors le clip on la
commence à tourner hier aujourd'hui on a
fini justement sur le parvis de saint
quentin et c'est une histoire qui
raconte c'est cette chanson mon ange en
fait et justement peut-être que les
saint quentinois vous vous ont aperçu en
plein tournage cet après midi on regarde
des images
extrait justement du making of qu'on a
réalisé dans cet après midi
n'en veut pas
c'était donc cet après midi à saint
quentin en yvelines à
montigny-le-bretonneux devant le théâtre
devant la scène nationale pour ceux qui
m'ont reconnue et qui vous ont peut-être
aperçu en train de finaliser ce clip
mondange donc la sortie du clip ce sera
pour quand
maintenant tout est fini on a fini le
tournage maintenant ça va prendre un peu
près quinze jours trois semaines de
montage on va dire fin octobre au plus
tard début novembre et le clip de
l'album pardon lui va sortir le 1er mai
lenteur 1er octobre donc d'albums de
mellick tire ça vous change un petit peu
aussi de votre vie d'avant parce que
vous l'avez dit vous avez été comédien
vous avez travaillé aussi sur la ville
de guyancourt pour la prévention
délinquance auprès des jeunes de
quartier oui parcours surprenant au fait
ben oui ben oui j'ai essayé un petit peu
s'il voulait de rester dans mon domaine
papa plusieurs branches et puis ça on a
fait partie vous avez vous êtes
intervenu aussi auprès de personnes
handicapées ou c'est tout ça ça se fait
toujours autour de la musique alors pour
vous la musique c'est le fil conducteur
c'est c'est quoi c'est fédérateur c'est
si ma vie quoi
c'est tout pour moi j'ai si l'histoire
des vies tout simplement et ces
expériences ont nourri l'écriture
devient tout à fait beau on parlait
aussi de personnes handicapées j'ai
participé au projet qui s'appelait en 10
x est justement c'était pour
apporter la musique à ces gens qu'on met
parfois aussi de côté donc c'était une
très bonne expérience il est très
enrichissante tant au niveau humain et
ça veut dire que pendant toutes ces
années vous avez écrit vous avez pris un
calepin et vous avez pris des notes pour
préparer l'album non moment vous a dit
je vais écrire j'ai une dizaine
quinzaine de chansons à écrire non en
fait c'est des gens aussi que moi un
petit peu poussé c'est vrai que ça reste
est en moi c'était une boule comme ça
puis ça m'a pris dix mois faire cet
album donc moi plan ça a été très
scolaire pendant dix mois vous vous êtes
appliqué une supplique réassorti de
l'année je n'ai rien fait du tout
l'année dernière que cet album parce que
j'enseigne aussi donc je rentrais le
soir je ne plonge et là dessus j'ai
passé beaucoup de nuits blanches c'est
un étang pour finir n'a pas pour
réaliser tout ça et les textes sont
sortis en fait si vous voulez c'est un
petit peu les expériences de la vie
convient que j'avais un petit peu envie
de raconter c'est beaucoup d'engagement
beaucoup de travail mais ensuite il faut
convaincre les maisons de disques on
sait que c'est difficile le marché du
disque se porte pas forcément très très
bien comment ça s'est passé pour vous
pour l'instant l'album il n'est pas
encore sorti mais c'est ce qui se passe
se passait derrière tout ça en fait
parce que là vous réalisez le disque il
faut le préparer et ensuite vous allez
des marchés en vente sur
toutes les plateformes internet de
téléchargement légal légal tout m'a fait
aimer c'est le mieux luigi tribu des
réelles sur le travail que vous avez
fait vous aller démarcher les maisons je
vais aller démarcher les maisons dit
j'ai quelques contacts j'ai aussi des
projets sur le canada pour l'été
prochain où la géla de la production là
bas donc voilà je vais essayer parce que
j'ai très attirés aussi par ce pays là
donc je vais essayer un petit peu de
travailler là dessus celle des scènes
aussi des scènes aussi bien sur les
scènes mais ce sera prévue à partir du
les vacances de février prochaine et
vous vous imaginez une star pétards
comment voyez les choses ces stars
c'est pas un peu pesé au lycée une vie
c'est un autre parcours donc c'est la
star c'est dangereux d'être une star
aussi parce que c'est éphémère et ça
peut être on peut tomber très rapidement
en étant une star donc si je préférais
la limite rester dans la durée
apporter quelque chose aux gens que mes
chansons leur parle justement qui s'y
retrouvent donc mon message c'est plutôt
celui ci et on va demander aux
téléspectateurs si eux aussi rêvent
peut-être d'être une star c'est la
question que nous avons posée
aujourd'hui à saint quentin en yvelines
ont ça ne me plaît pas ça ne séduit pas
samse dupas j'aurais aimé être une star
pour
pour pouvoir faire passer un message
mais une star non pas dans le show
business mais plutôt dans dans l'acte
politique et civique davantage le
financier je veux dire c'est clair il ya
beaucoup de gens je veux dire qu'ils
vont peut-être pas relever cet aspect là
mais je veux dire si cet esprit il est
clairement évident mais pourtant je dire
c'est un facteur qu'on démantèle
chanteur un chanteur maintenant marvin
gaye otis redding c'est le top
vers canet aussi
oui pour gagner de l'argent et pour être
célèbre dans le sport
c'est sympa d'être une star dans le
sport ça un certain mur hitchcock mais
devenir quelqu'un je veux dire qu'il y
aurait une forte visibilité à l'échelle
nationale qui pourrait faire
véhiculer des vraies idées plutôt que
des conneries qu'on
mais ce fils arrêtés n'ont pas trop ce
que j'aime bien ma tranquillité non
parce que
parce que bassée
trop versé par les médias et tout ça non
là on a plus personnalité
justement tout ce qu'on fait suit après
n'a plus de l'identité privé
être une star pour véhiculer un message
c'est votre ambition oui tout à fait
vous lire des tex d'ailleurs je vais
vous offrir album eh ben voilà que
j'étais déjà écouté aujourd'hui à la
rédaction mellick tiers-monde en jeu
donc l'album qui sortira le 1er octobre
le clip ensuite ce sera rapidement
ficelé puisque le tournage vient juste
de se finir et puis sera retrouvée sur
votre site internet et je viserai région
et vous pourrez venir nous voir pour
nous présenter tout ça merci mes
lecteurs du monde est revenu sur le
plateau l'édition du 7 8 à 2 ce 25
septembre avec la page environnement au
maximum mènent 16-1 invité mon me
rejoindra juste après ce reportage de
johanna soudry consacrée au travail de
marie noëlle fontan et les tisserandes
originaire de toulouse elle tisse à
partir de végétaux qu'elle trouve en
france au mexique au guatemala elle
expose en ce moment dans les yvelines à
viroflay
originaire de toulouse marie noëlle
fontang a longtemps vécu au guatemala
avant de s'installer à paris sa nouvelle
exposition est à l'image de sa vie entre
europe et amérique centrale marie noëlle
a tissé des fils chez ma mère et qui
tissent et en fait qui nous faisait le
vêtement est donc quand on est enfant on
copie on copie les parents voilà est
elle au lieu de faire du tricot altis
est donc que moi j'ai fait pareil pareil
pas tout à fait puisque marie noëlle
expérimente amoureuse des plantes elles
collectent les végétaux qu'elle trouve
en france au mexique au guatemala pour
les incorporer au fil alors du yucca
ianao france pour son en trouve dans les
appartements mais c'est hugh cas que je
trouve ces
tropicale en fait les y en a beaucoup
qui viennent du salvador el salvador la
plante national du salvador c'est le
yucca chaque plante est une découverte
mais pour une bonne manipulation tout
doivent être suffisamment longue sens
avéré trop lisse marie noëlle travail le
fils et le végétal feuilles racines ou
écorces se mêlent aux tissages ses
créations étonnantes rappelle tantôt des
insectes tantôt des lianes des liens en
faisant écho à des racines filmé par le
salvadorien guy hiernaux calonne et mise
en musique par le guatémaltèque igor des
gandarias racines aériennes pour une
ambiance tropicale où la nature est
omniprésente
janati s'est beaucoup là bas mais tout
n'est pas trop hôpital nous c'est juste
l'idée
marie noëlle conjugue ainsi exotisme et
locales ça c'est du boulot
des serveurs de la basse et du lin que
l'on trouve en normandie les racines
aériennes sont à découvrir en entrée
libre à l'écu de france à viroflay
jusqu'au 18 octobre marie noëlle fontan
sera régulièrement présente sur le site
l'occasion pour les visiteurs d'échanger
avec l'artiste
le 7 8 en direct entre 18 et 19 heures
du lundi au jeudi sur téléphiles 78
voici le rappel des titres de ce 25
septembre les salariés de la mgen
inquiets pour leur emploi une
manifestation nationale s'est déroulée à
paris aujourd'hui relayée également à la
verrière nous en parlions en début
d'édition envie une entreprise
d'insertion qui s'occupe de recycler du
matériel électroménager dorénavant
plantes et attrapes elle les salariés
signent des contrats entre quatre et
cinq mois en vie ouvrira au public le 6
octobre électroménagers à bas prix et
puis c'est bien connu le sport c'est la
santé un dicton qui a pris tout son sens
ce week end c'était à base de loisirs
vous étiez peut-être avec l'opération
sentez vous sport voilà pour le rappel
des titres le sport c'est la santé et
puis bien sûr le rucher du côté de la
verrière vous verrez le reportage tout à
l'heure au cours de cette édition c'est
la fin donc de cette partie de ce rappel
des titres dans un instant la chronique
environnement maximum n 20 me rejoindre
pour l'instant les salarié es de la
mutuelle générale de l'éducation
nationale s'inquiètent pour leur avenir
restructuration en cours avec des
incidences sur le site de la verrière
toutes les explications
des salariés de la mgen inquiets pour
leur emploi ont manifesté ce matin à
paris dans les rangs de l'intersyndicale
des employés de l'antenne de la verrière
principale cause de leur mécontentement
la révision annoncée de la convention
collective de la fédération des
établissements hospitaliers et des aides
à la personne l'aménagement du zoo
propre à la mgen et l'externalisation de
certains services leinen s'est pas donné
les moyens de faire une équipe en
intérieur pour prouver en quoi
l'externalisation et est forcément
meilleure mais en quoi on aurait pu leur
faire différemment à l'intérieur en
termes de ressources deuxièmement
l'ensemble des personnels à bénéficier
régulièrement des formations et 6 ans
d'aujourd'hui il ya un dysfonctionnement
c'est la responsabilité de la mgen de
devoir donner tous les moyens pour
former et adapter le personnel aux
évolutions qui sont demandés du côté de
la direction locale de la mgen jean
ignace de bayou affirme qu'une
réorganisation est nécessaire pour
revenir à un équilibre financier
l'établissement verrière roi perd plus
d'argent qu'il n'en gagne parmi les
usages remis en cause on retrouve
notamment les rythmes de travail et
l'institut marcel rivière par exemple
nous avons
l'habitude de travailler avec des
absences de cycle horaires salariés
n'ont pas de cycle régulier ça a un coût
en équivalent temps plein sur une année
et donc c'était un usage qui est
dénoncée qu'on doit on doit faire des
cycles la mgen compte 33 établissements
répartis dans toute la france ce qui
représente un total de 4000 salariés
pour les 200 employés de la verrière une
seule certitude pour l'instant une
externalisation partir du 1er décembre
de la restauration et de l'entretien le
directeur assure que les employés de ces
services seront repris dans les
entreprises sous traitantes
un message entendu mais pas satisfaisant
pour l'intersyndicale qui craint des
suppressions de postes